what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am with
taylor the sparkle queen from tic toc
what's up guys
um so what she does is she does a lot of
content about masculine versus feminine
energy
and she uh we've just been having a
conversation
about if we think like men have problems
would you say
you were you're saying oh we should feel
bad for men yeah
and like i'm all all i talk about is how
we shouldn't talk [ __ ] about men we
shouldn't talk down for them but like i
also don't have sympathy for you
well not for all of you right okay yeah
fair enough yeah
some yes maybe but like for the most
part like
yeah well i come from i have brothers
and i just
i don't know i i have more than i would
say you do i have two brothers too
but my my brothers are very masculine
buff very attractive well-dressed
well-spoken men
okay so like uh
so you don't have much
okay regardless regardless um she's
never seen kevin samuels
ever ever and i'm gonna show it to her
for the first time
and i'm just really excited i'm excited
too people been telling me that i need
to watch this guy and i have no idea
on youtube oh man let's see what this
guy's talking about
can you hear it
oh i was just um i was just going back
to
the young lady that you were just
speaking to earlier
and um you said that you believe all men
cheat
that night you better off accepting it
i don't know i just feel like that's not
like i mean i might be wrong like you
you know no no
i am 25. in the mammal kingdom
man of old somebody said oh in the
mammal kingdom is it the norm for the
male of the species to make a monogamous
parabon for life
no i understand that
so you want humans to be different
um okay what do you think so far i
actually i haven't seen this clip so
that's not where i thought he'd start
um i have done
let's say a lot of i've had a lot of
conversations with men and
um about this particular topic like
are all men compelled to spread spread
their seed because they're
uh polygamous creatures and they can
have multiple women pregnant at once
and like i'm not gonna say he's wrong
i mean i'm i would not make the bold
statement to say all men cheat right
right because you shouldn't like blanket
statement anyone
but do all men have more of a capacity
to cheat
yeah yeah totally for that fact right
there right and then like even when you
are in a marriage
and then your wife gets pregnant like
once we pop out a baby for one as it is
like the couple of weeks
leading up to right when that baby's
about to come out and then when the baby
comes out and then
a few weeks after like you're kind of
out of commission down there
that's what i always talk about how do
you think it's okay to like
cheat on your wife if she gets cancer
like you never know if someone's gonna
get sick
that's what i think about a lot because
like they'll often say like if your like
wife is isn't like meeting your needs
like a lot of times they step
out and i'm like well what if what if
someone gets sick wow i wasn't thinking
about like terminal
illness i was thinking about like
incapacitated for
a short period of time because also like
when you think about it like especially
in the celebrities like they always say
oh he cheated on her while she was
pregnant and it was like
i understand how that happened i'm not
condoning it but like
so if you had a kid with someone and
they cheated would you leave
hi he i would like to say and i don't
know this because i'm not there but i
would like to say that i'm progressive
enough to be like
go do what you got to do don't tell me
about it really oh that's i don't a lot
you're not alone though there's a lot of
girls that think
like why like cause yourself the [ __ ]
hype break their man like
men physically need to ejaculate like
it's part of their biology
they need to get off yeah and if they
don't they get sick like
that these are just like facts like men
need to have sex as they say men need to
spread their seed like
they physically like need to have sex
that's so i was not expecting that
answer from you
i like seriously was not that is not
what i was expecting at all
[Music]
i i think i'd probably leave i couldn't
trust him then like then i
see that's the thing if you talk about
it and you have trust and you say and
i'm like yo
like yeah i know you're you're going to
do what you're going to do like
make and and also men have more capacity
to make it just sex
than women so like i have faith that
like in that happen because i could be
like a three to four it's a six month
period
yeah and what i'm expecting like why
would i make it so he had to hide it
i would be like go do what you have to
do all the guys are going to slide in
your deals
[Laughter]
i was
i'm talking about that one specific
window if i pop out a kid okay
you're saying in the case like if you
pop if you could not fulfill your
husband like sex yeah because i'm not
gonna be like blowing like sucking you
off and like giving blow jobs all the
time
especially [ __ ] pregnant yeah i'm not
gonna be doing that okay because
i was just wondering because like it's
interesting because for me like i i
think i would leave
like honestly i just i would i'd go
crazy
but that's so funny i know i'm not in
the situation right now so i can't
like i can't say 100 for sure but
because of like as we talked about how
you have to understand the masculine if
you really want to be with a man like
heike that is part of it understanding
that these men like they need to have
sex okay more so than a woman needs to
have sex they're gonna
they're gonna agree with you
have this whole monogamous parabon what
was the life expectancy
in biblical times how old like 35 i'm
not mistaken it was
like i'm not sure
honestly i think it was like 60 or
something like that no
about 45 years
most people died early mm-hmm
so what's the problem with me and
exercising their options i mean
i mean presuming that you want you only
married
do i want to be married yes do you want
to have children
yes i'm in it um i already have one
right now maybe one more
yikes he's like yeah
he hates single buttons
like the way his chin turned up like
that when she said
she already had one kid i'm like he does
not
pay bills after you're pregnant i mean
no
wait wait hold on pause again if i have
a man
and he is going and i get pregnant and i
don't have to [ __ ] work from the time
that i am
i don't know what in my last month or so
like
35 weeks to the time that the kid is
like four or five months
and he's going to work and he's doing
his [ __ ] if he wants to go [ __ ] somebody
else because i can't give it to him i'm
not gonna be mad
that's what they say you shouldn't be
back that's right that's what kevin
samuels
in that time we know and you still go to
work and you come home and i'm chilling
like do it i would probably
realistically because we as women like
our [ __ ] gets tired
i would probably be happy he's leaving
me alone like don't come home smelling
like her
don't come home like you know what i
mean if you kept it a secret you didn't
find out
you're cool no i would we would talk
about it you would talk about it but
it's like don't be disrespectful
right there's a difference between me
knowing that like you went on a weekend
trip with the boys
right i don't know what happened i don't
have to know what happened
i didn't have to see it but you're
coming back happier and see if it's
something that i maybe couldn't have
done for you in that moment
yeah there's a difference between like
we're having a conversation about being
open
for a time period of being open and like
you
yeah there's a difference between like
we're having
a conversation about it and like being
and being open and i'm letting you go do
what you have to do because you're a man
and i understand that you're a man
and i understand that it will actually
probably make you love me more because
you're gonna go [ __ ] her and you're
gonna wish you were having sex with me
you were speaking music to this mandy i
swear because
in this kevin that's what he talks about
how like these are men they're gonna do
they're gonna do
like but no
it's it's interesting because for me
like i just
you're right there's a difference i
don't think it's cheating if you like
have like permission so to say
exactly but i could dab too
jealous i couldn't do it i live in miami
how much money is it going to take for a
family oh yeah it's really expensive to
live down here
so you think a man should you think a
man who's going to take on a woman with
somebody else's kids gonna
make that kind of money and not explore
what is what's in miami
i just feel like i understand that
before you feel what you do
tell me what a man who's going to be a
stepfather
and have to put up with being a
stepfather
and then has to be a provider for a
woman who
has a child that she was married to you
want me to dance
what kind of money is that man gonna
need to make to be a step farm
i think you should be much more happy
that somebody's willing to even consider
being a stepfather
you agree with that absolutely yeah you
you asked me a little while ago if i
would date somebody with kids and i had
my stipulations right and i was like
yeah probably not
sorry i'm just checking something really
yeah it's working okay
yeah no i mean people can't act like kid
like they act like
a kid is nothing sometimes when they're
dating like it's no big deal but it's
it's a big deal it's a huge deal it's a
huge deal it's like being a step parent
that's a
big figure in someone's life that's a
lot of responsibility
right and do you want to take on that
responsibility this kid has its own
personality
it's its own needs and things that you
don't know about that you just have to
come in and
be responsible for well and he talks a
lot about how the issue is that like men
will come in
and they could like this is what i was
telling you about with like
men's like certain men's rights that
like issues and one of the issues that
a man could raise a kid for like 10
years let's say 15 years he has no
legal right to that kid if it's not his
even if he raised it like to see it
whatever
and then they'd split and then he's like
falling in love with this child
yeah and then they also talk about like
parenting dynamics
i don't know if they're going to talk
about it on this but like like
would you allow someone that's not his
dad to spank your kid
yikes that's like stuff i've i never
thought about you know
yeah i haven't thought about that
because we don't have we don't have kids
guys
yeah let's not get into the shot shall
we because you're running married to the
baby
i don't want the second man to do more
than the baby danny
and that's crazy that is crazy
i get where you're coming from when i
trust me i really like you i like the
way that like
you're very honest and you're very
straightforward so i understand where
you're coming from
in a lot of ways but i also believe that
it's not about the money or how much
money a man makes that's going to make
him want to cheat i feel like if he's
just happy in his relationship
no all to no
[Music]
that's true
[Music]
so what you're saying is your one vagina
is supposed to satiate a man
who has the ability to provide for a
family of four in miami
what do you bring what do you and your
one vagina bring it to the table it's so
great and wonderful
to offset everything that means with
your kid that you already have i mean i
feel like
maybe i won't make as much money as him
but i'm able to make
close i'm going to be able to make how
much is he gonna have to make to take
care of a family of four to be
responsible for it
two hundred fifty thousand dollars a
year minimum miami how much is he gonna
have to make
at least four hundred thousand oh what
percentage of me make four hundred
thousand
not not that many and i gotta be reached
oh dress size um
i wear a medium large depending on the
fabric do you have sauce
yeah your waistline honestly
because you wear everything stretchy
what do you mean like an actual dress
that's it
i was just wearing one earlier what size
was it it should be 2 4 6
twelve fourteen exactly um i
don't um i just i don't understand
because i don't wear anything that zips
up i weigh 190.
i'll tell you again i'm 5 10.
you're not fit oh my god what is that
like a sound a becky please
yeah he'll like play sound effects like
oh my god yeah so she like has a kid
she has a kid she's 5 10. she wants a
man that
makes over four hundred thousand dollars
a year that's in miami she already is a
kid she's 25.
she already has a kid she's 25. she is
one nine
she's 190 and she doesn't even know what
size she is in a dress that drips up
the zips up with me and she has no
fashion she knows she just doesn't want
to say it
because she's yeah she's i mean just off
those stacks she's got to be like a 12.
yeah that's what i was thinking she's
195
10. that's a little shorter than me
she's like 10 12 i bet
she um i wouldn't even i realistically
wouldn't give her a 10. just based off
the way black women are shaped like
she's going to be hip
like more curvy like yeah she's probably
like a 12 or 14. and she had a kid
so there's already a child that came out
of those hips yeah
yeah okay so
that's man he's gonna go in 19 and 190
[Music]
you weigh more than a man
and i
you think that a man who's making four
hundred thousand dollars should come in
and be a step daddy to a five foot ten
them to two hundred
average no no
that's what you want to believe yeah
i have how many men do you talk to on a
regular basis
i've talked to thousands over the years
he's like i talked to people coming here
25 years old and trying to school me
with a kid let me i mean you coming in
with not everything
but what they don't want how about this
what men don't want to do
is have to go make themselves 400 000
men and take care of somebody else's kid
damn talk to him i'm bringing something
to the table as well
for 100 000 so that don't mean she's
bringing fries to a burger don't mean
nothing oh my god
where's your child's father um he owns
his own company what does he do that he
he could be a shoeshine man
right he could be a contracting company
what does he do
he owns a contracting company what does
he do like
landscaping and stuff like that like
building houses contracting atlanta
he builds houses it's actually good
money and like construction they're
totally
yeah those are two very different things
yeah landscaping and contracting are two
different things
he's a general contractor he has a
general contracting company how much
money does he make
i'm not sure about it you should know
because he should be paying you child
support so you should know
and your baby daddy's a general
contractor
no offense to you sir but i know general
contractors
ain't paid like that they're not
he has no profession and if he owns his
own company is he steady listening
he doesn't have a profession
so you can't tell me he makes anywhere
close to 400 000
so you think a man should come in to be
with a woman
who had a baby for a general contractor
at 18.
190 pounds and you worried about
cheating
wait no okay
okay oh my god like don't get me wrong i
definitely understand where you're
coming from with a lot of things i just
i
i feel like sometimes when you do speak
you speak from
like a one-sided in a once
like one-minded like type of way like
i understand that 300 000 views on every
video with me
in the comment section saying thank you
i ain't just no i'm not saying that
you're wrong i'm speaking for i'm saying
i am speaking for the men who cannot
tell you the truth
damn she can't talk
how i speak why don't you understand
this men don't want to pay for nobody
else's kid
men don't want women to weigh more than
them at their height that part
you heard this you know this you can't
do anything about a kid but you can't do
something about your height about your
weight and about
and that's the one thing that women have
like we can always lose weight men can't
grow
like you know what i'm saying like okay
you can always like get thinner and like
yeah shape and bed can't like get taller
right but i can make sure that at 5
8 i don't weigh more than a 5 8 man yeah
yeah people well they'll act like that's
asking so
much it's not like it's really that was
like literally
the first thing how did i really start
this journey of self-discovery and my
transition and changing my
vibration shifting my energy i became
dedicated to my fitness and my weight
loss
it changed my mental state it made me
feel better about myself
i'm approached by different men now like
i got my [ __ ] together because i didn't
want to be a 10
12 i wanted to be a six eight yeah wait
so
did um you lost 20 pounds yeah isn't it
interesting
how much like more attention you get
like after so i've always
my weight has fluctuated right so like
i'm like i gained weight in quarantine
so it is very interesting but i know it
already because i've
lived it my entire life you know what i
mean so like i know the type of looks
that i get when i
am in a size i haven't been at 12 since
i was like a child but since i was in
like
when i was in a 10 versus like now that
i'm in a six yeah you know what i mean i
absolutely know it and like
it was a motivator and a driver to make
me lose weight and i feel better about
myself
and i don't have to worry about when i
am talking to a guy if he wasn't
interested in me because i was bad yeah
yeah wow i've never thought about that
if you've been
heavier you have to think about that you
know what i mean and so it's like
it's really easy to be afraid of
something that you've experienced
before i know what it's like being fat
yeah i was always heavy until i turned
wish this girl's 25 maybe she'll lose
weight
i didn't lose weight until i was always
like heavier in like 12s and 14s
i turned 25 i decided i was going to
coachella and i became hell-bent on
losing the weight
really and and that was in 2016 and i
dropped 30 pounds and i like
successfully
like and then by the end of that summer
i had lost a total of 50 pounds
really so i was like size 6 like really
fit
like really great and i maintained that
size
for about two and a half years and i
like slowly like with drinking when i
put a little bit more weight on and then
the quarantine hit and i put on about 15
to like 20 pounds
and i was like no way i was like this is
this is not what we're about to do like
i'm not
having you so wait until you get a
boyfriend
why because men always like to go out to
eat and like do things
you have to be you have to be on
yourself you don't know
i'm back on it but like when i first
started dating one yeah i did
i gave 10 pounds so fast because we were
just going out to eat
another good thing about me is like i
cook right so it's like when i do get
this man
like i'll just be like oh babe i'm gonna
cook and then i'll just make us some
really healthy [ __ ] you hear that
none
that somebody should come in and
400 000 even if he's making 200 how much
do you plan on making
i plan on um honestly making around four
hundred thousand dollars is what is
[ __ ]
um i don't have a degree sir but not not
everyone needs a degree
what would you like to make a 400 what
high income skill do you have to bring
in right now bartending company
mobile bartending
how long have you owned this business
i've owned it for more than two years
more than two years did you go to the
bank to get financing where'd you go to
get your initial round of funding
i'm financing my company myself
bootstrapping
i appreciate you for that you go to
college
i would like to say something to that
because i had said earlier like i would
love for a guy to make 500 000
a year like my goal for this year is to
make 200 000 a year so it's like
not so ridiculous for me to want
somebody that is a high earner
because and like i do plan on making
that type of money
and like you know in 2019 i was i sat
just under 100
000 a year like that's not a far
fetch for me you know like um
yeah so do you do you think like um but
you know men don't care about your body
i know which is so great
they care about your body though
he talks about this all the time right
but he's still he's asking her i guess
just to like poke and prod her like what
does she make and what does she plan on
bringing to the table you know what i
mean
just to see but exactly it's like i
could i could be a barista at starbucks
i could be the waitress that zac efron
is stating a waitre well not anymore
they broke up but he was having a
waitress from like
some random restaurant yeah men don't
care about that but exactly but they do
care if you're fit and they care if
you're beautiful
yeah no that's very true that's like
she's pretty though like she's got a
nice face
yeah she just before getting started
your business
um i was working at a restaurant before
then but this was
a server hostess or what i was a server
and a hostess
okay so what restaurant
um it's prime 112 on the beach right
so i think i've heard of that you have
skills to be a server i've been a server
but that's not a high income skill i
understand and now you're a
mobile hookah whatever is this your
vehicle
what do you mean no this is basically
like okay um
i have a lot of clients who booked me
for different events so if they're
having weddings they're having baby
showers they're having
any type of event they're booking for
those types of events what are you
agreeing
what do you mean i bring my my supplies
my um
my mixers my bar my whole setup you know
okay uh and you are
certified barking yes i am and i have
girls who work with me as well
and you make in the contractors
what do you mean you don't they're not
employees they're contractors yeah yes
they're contractors
all right and you've been doing this
business for how long this business is
going to make
a half million dollars a year take home
i think you can okay how much
i got a business question yes how much
would you need to make
gross to take home 400 000
damn does she know i would need to make
at least
six if i'm not mistaken
okay six what 600
six hundred thousand dollars gross oh
i'm sorry
to bring home 400 000 net
yeah how much would you need to make
gross to bring home 400 000
i'm not i'm not sure i feel like i'm not
doing that i don't know
i have to do the math on that what do
you think
can you can you tell me i don't know i
can but but see i already know because i
have the skills i'm saying
you know as soon as you say you think
the business can make that i want to see
how you know
um i just feel like okay the reason why
i said that my business can
make i don't know young lady i don't
want to know what you feel we're talking
business i want to know what you think
and know
right i don't know exactly how much i
would have
well typically mo typically a
conservative estimate is you bring home
10 percent
of your gross right so if you had a four
million dollar business
that doesn't but that's not for everyone
not when she's making a cash business
you're just you're just thinking that no
money come in money come out
i can she doesn't know what she's
talking about but i will say with when
it comes to certain businesses like
if you have a low overhead head you
don't you're not bringing home
10 net profit like yourself i have
i own a business so i i know like and i
have i own a business with a very low
overhead
so i also know yeah
i don't know i understand and what i'm
basically saying is
i asked why she works
see in this you ladies people tend to
think today
the rules of business don't exist
anymore because you got a cell phone
in the internet you're not a business
person
you don't have to set up a business to
make that kind of money and to make that
kind of money
takes gross net
yeah takes some skill yeah
i understand so
okay the reason why i'm going gonna
bring home what he's
making on a man bringing that home has
to have
a high income skill
not a hookah a mobile nothing
sir okay i hear what you're saying
you'd be shocked at the power of the
internet um
you can learn so much on the internet
about running your business no no but
i'm saying like
like charlie demilio what does she do
right
girl set for life she sells everything i
don't like
what if she dances right and not even
that well
and the crazy thing is like she makes so
much money
like that's what i'm saying like that
everyone desires
the reason why i feel that well i don't
i don't
feel i know that my business will
grow exponentially not only because of
the people skills that i have but also
because i'm not only studying a service
i'm also selling a product as well
um right now i'm in the um workings to
get a liquor license
for my drinks that i make my custom
drinks so this is the business that i
know for sure 100 000
a year i get great and if it was that if
it was easy
that easy for a high school graduate to
make 400 000
a year how many people will rush down to
miami to do what you're doing
not not everybody has the ma'am okay i'm
not going
i don't want to do this i don't know i'm
going to leave i'm going to leave you're
not going to argue because you know what
you're talking about
that's when it comes right there there's
no argument you absolutely do not know
what you're talking about
wow and i'm trying to tell you something
but i get it
so many people tell women yeah go out
and pursue your dreams and such and so
forth
you're a mother of one telling me that
you think
running a mobile who could borrow
something is gonna make a half a million
dollars
take time by yourself it's nearly
impossible to have can i just say
another thing as well
because i don't even i don't even bring
that here's the thing what you can do
what you can do what you can do is what
you can understand
is even away from the business
ultimately what i'm trying to say is you
you
you're also in denial and delusion it's
hard to tell you
well you can see and it's about
believing that i look for something
like i'm open-minded and i'm hearing
everything that you're saying but you're
not
but you're not accepting that money is
not free
if what you're saying is plausible
there are people who know more about
business and have better
sales management bartending and
all kind of experience than you and
they're not making that
i don't feel like all of my money is
going to come from my business
i do also know that because right now
i'm in real estate i just uh purchased
my first
there you are you got all these things
going on no if she just purchased her
first property at 25
that's not she just purchased her first
property she just said she purchased
okay so then she is making money and it
might be a lot under the table so she
might not have those specific numbers
but she's making cash money
in liquor yeah i mean maybe not half a
million
right not right okay she's doing okay i
actually i actually know that okay
at the end of the day i'm very smart i
know that the business itself is not
going to bring me
i'm sorry you can never stay in an
argument i'm very smart
because you i can't describe why
but when you say i'm very smart you just
sound stupid
i can't tell you why that's not a good
thing that
i know that for sure but it can get
okay it can't get to a good scale and i
know that as well
real estate is going to help me get to
the point you took this the shark tank
they would not buy it
no way they would buy it well duh it's
not a it's not a million dollar
investing idea
i did based upon what business knowledge
what do you mean you shouldn't write
your own business plan
you're too close to who wrote your
marketing plan
i'm doing my marketing plan by myself no
one did it for me it means you're
exactly on instagram
you're right so go back to my shark tank
lion's den show
so many people think they know what the
hell they're talking about you wrote a
business plan based upon your
incomplete insufficient knowledge of an
industry
or marketplace what you did is you took
a business plan template and you put in
what you think
but if you took that to bank of america
and tried to get a loan
and say here's what i got is collateral
and here's who i am
here's my business plan they'd say
denied
they would not give you a loan
i understand you're right i can't do
everything by myself
and like china you can't have your
business
man it is unlikely to make a half a
million dollars a year as
anybody you have to have high income
skills for that
not bartender hookah real estate power
ranger
contractor oh my god do you say power
don't have a college degree
you don't have any you don't have any
real experience in the work well except
serving
i'm not saying that you don't have
intelligence or ability
but what you don't have is competence
competence gets compensated but see the
world will allow you ladies to walk
around here just talk these fantasy
fantasies and blah blah blah you got a
kid that's seven years older
you don't have time to be a mother and
run a half a million dollar net business
you don't have a ton of time and then to
turn around and be asking a question
about a man who
is bringing that kind of money home or
even half of that
and you questioning whether or not he
decides that no i mean i wasn't
questioning that honestly
whether he wants to get some other side
because he has to bring it back to the
cheating thing that we started out with
i totally forgot that's where we started
asking you do you believe that that's
that was i believe that any man
making that kind of money has options to
exercise and if you're lucky enough to
get one
uh look at your baby daddy nes uh is it
better than what you had
i swear these women start flirting with
him by the end
i'm like is he married no um
because he probably is just still a man
about town his 50 year old self he's
probably hooking up with everybody
and he knows which is probably
absolutely why because he is
he has options and he knows he has
options well he actually
he he's been married twice so
yeah this is he i think that's why he
doesn't really like like he's very
short with women because it sounded like
i don't know if this is true
but i'm like it hurts one of my
commenters told me that he was like
dying and his wife left him and then
like he survived
so is he one of those men out there that
hate women i don't think he hates women
i think he believes that women aren't
held accountable
and i would agree with him on like some
level held held accountable for what so
like
for example um their weight like the
bodybuilding see i hold women
accountable for their weight
i actually lost a follower on tick tock
when because i commented on this other
girl's video who was complaining about
how
she is a smaller dating pool because
she's overweight and i was like
hell yeah you have a smaller dating pool
because you're overweight that's a fact
right either do something about it or
don't complain right well that's what
and that's what he like for example like
the body positivity movement
like like that's what he means like
women aren't held accountable instead of
saying
yeah you're fat i'm all over body
positivity love yourself
and yeah at whatever size you are
because i have been multiple sizes i
love my body yet whatever size i am but
i do know i'm not going to go get johnny
with the abs
over there if i have extra rolls like
i'm just
i mean maybe some sometimes guys that
are buff like
want chubbier women because they like
want you to be soft but like
when you want to talk about those
percentages how much smaller
is the percentage of the buff guy that
wants the thick
background and they get so mad like a
lot of times they'll get so mad if like
guys don't want to date them
and i'm not like super skinny like i
mean i dress well but i'm definitely not
like tiny
by any means but i'm not going to be mad
if like men aren't into six foot ginger
oh no
like not everyone finds you attractive
and it is what it is and you have to
accept that right right
and that's what he means like women
aren't held accountable like
it's like a girl can like like like
girls will still be told to love
themselves when like
they're overweight they don't like their
kids they have spending problems
no and they'll be like sis love yourself
treat yourself like should you
this is what i told the girl in the
comment i said people who love
themselves care
about their physical fitness yeah and
it's and it's also like
like a lifestyle like people like get up
at six a.m
like that's a completely i woke up at
six well this morning was seven because
i have it's my later morning but
four out of four days a week i wake up
at 6 a.m and i go hiking yeah
and every single day that's like a
mindset and when i talk
as i've been doing this mind shift shift
what was the first thing i did was the
fitness i started building communities
around fitness
i started being dedicated to working out
and i came up with a routine that i did
not miss
and i realized like three weeks into it
i had a lazy day
and i missed my workout and by like four
o'clock the afternoon i started having a
[ __ ] meltdown
yeah i was not mentally okay and i was
like okay i can't do that anymore well
and the thing is like why men get so mad
is because like
women have no problem saying like you
ain't [ __ ] if you don't get a job
like and they're like you ain't [ __ ] if
you don't have a flat stomach
like if you're fat you're in [ __ ] but
they can't say that because they'll
kill
girl i know it i told you like i was
like i'm getting this [ __ ] together
summer is coming it's about to be hot
girl sometimes i'm not trying to play
around
but you you get what i'm saying i
absolutely that's why men are so
frustrated is because they feel like we
can say whatever we want
about math and they can't say anything
no i will tell you
lose some weight let me see i think
there's like 50 you got a man that's
making like kind of money is it better
than your
bd then you
you laid down and gave that man the most
important thing you give any man in the
world
a child a child and he got it for being
fries on mcdonald's
[Music]
that's why i tell you ladies on time yes
that is absolutely swallow but you can't
ask norton
bd yeah you're not going to level up
more than like that's the first person i
gave you a chance to sit down with
somebody because if you really want to
do a business
you need to get somebody who understands
business that you also need
right now right you need a business
mentor
don't do it you need to take a class
because you're too close you've done all
those things
she actually wasn't like a lot of the
girls that come on are like a lot more
disordered like she was more
level-headed than like a lot of the
girls so he picks these women
intentionally that have like don't have
a clue
they uh no no they like he doesn't know
like oh
so he does this on ig live um i don't
know where he does it because i don't
like watch it live
but like basically like these women like
call in
and like yeah he just destroys them like
that all shows have producers
right and i'm telling you they pick
women
that don't have a clue i'm sure i'm sure
they do
because the conversation would be
different like you said even i surprised
you with some of the things that i said
they might not cast me to go on his show
right for that
or maybe they would because they
probably would because of the 500
000 thing like they probably would say
like your standards are too high
but then i would turn around and tell
them like they're not because like i
make
you know what i mean like okay i'm not
there but i have plenty i have plans and
goals of like
he's like well how are you gonna get
there how am i gonna get there i'm going
to have my own tv show right
like the having the tick tock is it
means having a tv show when you make
when you're on tv you make
five thousand ten thousand dollars an
episode you make those larger salaries
and then you have brand deals and you
have sponsorships and you have all of
those things and you have merchandise
and you have
a store and people just wanna buy things
because your face is on it like that's
where i'm going
yeah no but like this is what he would
say he would say they don't they don't
care
the men don't care they do not care
right well that's why i'm working on all
this other [ __ ]
that's why i'm in the gym that's why i'm
trying to you know
put down my or not pushed it well i
don't know like shift my masculine
energy that's why i am doing all of the
other things that i
know men actually right now that's what
i'm saying like i think that you would
agree with some of the stuff and i think
you disagree with others
yeah i don't think you're like on one
side or the other yeah i'm just telling
you like when they hear half a million
they like pick you
right you know what i'm saying but yeah
so what did you think of him overall
would you watch him again i would watch
him again you don't think he's a
misogynist
you don't think i think he's right i
think he's out here telling people the
[ __ ] truth
people don't like to hear the truth okay
and like that's why people are upset
but don't you think it would have been
more helpful when you were 21 to have
heard this
oh my god if i knew what attachment
styles were when i was 20
if i like knew what men were actually
also granted i was a late bloomer so i
really wasn't even dating like i didn't
start dating until i was 26.
but like when i did decide to like throw
myself into the dating world if i had a
little bit of education on like
what was actually like going on out
there like what was actually going to
attract a man
what was going to repel a man right you
know what i mean oh my god i would be
i would i'd probably be wiped up by now
yeah not even probably i would
yeah because this shit's quantum leaping
and going fast so if any of you are out
there that want to slide into my m's
my dms don't wait because the other men
they're circling they're around so
really
okay oh yeah big time yeah um that's all
i have though
thanks for coming up this is fun this
was fun
i will talk to you guys next time do not
forget to subscribe i'm trying to get to
20 000 subscribers that's a big goal for
the channel
hit that subscribe button and bring the
notification bell